Magnus I don't think he's enjoying these
last couple games
yeah no I think he for sure would have
lost a win by a 10-point margin but now
Gianna's closing it down a little bit he
plays the alakai with Knight to G8
Robert what do you make of this opening
he loves doing stuff like that Magnus
has done this in olympiads he's done
plenty of classical games uh what's it
called the Norwegian lion or rat or
whatever I forget what the name of the
opening is where he puts his Knight on
H5 like the North Sea variation
something to that effect
exactly yeah so we see Bishop seven it
looks pretty alright here for black
white is the bishop error but the Nano
C3 is slightly misplaced in on the other
hand black is pretty nice development
and the Bishops for the moment aren't
that effective and I love this maneuver
here by Magnus that E6 I wish I could
put my knight to F6 and back to G8 on my
first two moves and get a position like
this I don't know how he does it but we
just saw a bad opening payoff for Yan
and now for Magnus it's the reverse
where his bad opening or not bad but
questionable it looks pretty good for
black at the stage
exactly this Knight is jumping around
now it has to go back to H2 and Oliver
wait 1965 that's a pawn when Knight F5
check is probably what he's looking for
and there might is there King F6 there
no way
uh he goes for it he he wins King of the
Hill he wins King of the Hill
and then you can end the game yeah
that's done King of the Hill we got this
and but the King on E5 is somehow safe
enough because Queen C3 check there's D4
and the King will Scurry back to F6 and
the F5 Knight actually is hanging after
Queen C3 so what a decision from Magnus
he's getting away with it
yeah king of six and now he's completely
safe 94 do not take us after 364 your
king is in a deadly check but maybe
rookie eight defend the night and if he
gets a king to G7 it's just over Robert
and if he trades on E6 and brings the
king to E7 that also looks very good so
Queen C3 I really like that move because
you take on D4 Queen takes D4 check your
King has to go to G5 and there might be
to be Queen D2 Queen D4 so kind of draw
by repetition
right so let's see what Magnus is gonna
do this looks like a nice little move by
John I don't see how this king is
getting out of here
I don't either I think I would just swap
Knights and D4 and try to make that draw
if it is indeed a draw
right oh queen bees Robert 1966 D4
Knight takes Rook takes E1 and then you
take the Knight what a find
that is a beautiful variation with the
Knight on E6 it's free for white to take
oh we take it from The Rook but there's
no way not E5 it's over there's no
follow-up and Magnus wins a brilliant
game Queen B6 there are you kidding me
I'm looking for a draw he finds a way to
get a victory there Magnus Carlson I
know it hasn't been his absolute best
because of some of the mistakes he's
made but he's played a really great day
of chess